Now, you're going to
set up your cluster.
Open a browser, go to the public
hosting of the server on port 8080.
You can see mine here.
If you can't connect check
the security rules for the server and
make sure the port
eighty eighty is open.
Log on with username admin and it's
pretty clear what you should do here.
Launch install wizard,
name your cluster.
Next, select the stack,
this determines the software
versions installed on the cluster.
Choose the newest one HDP2.3.
This stands for
hurting works data platform.
Here, you list the host names of
the computers in the cluster or
the internal host names.
I had a copy.
Copy goes into here.
Upload your SSH private key and
change the user account to Ubuntu.
Okay, hit register and
confirm, everything should
install register just fine.
You should see a big list of services
that you can install on the cluster.
For now, just do HDFS, Yarn,
Zookeeper and Umbari Metrics.
Now, you can choose the hosts
that the various services run on.
Umbari has reasonable suggestions, but
you can see here that there
is one service per computer.
Instead let's move the metrics
collector to this computer, so
it runs with the zookeeper server.
So, this is 172.31 15 30,
Metrics collector, so
let's put it there, then hit next.
Now, you need to assign data nodes and
clients.
Node manager here worked with Yarn to
keep track of the data node resources.
Client, installs all these
clients on machines.
Since these hosts are running
master components,
make these three data
nodes with node managers.
And next, you shouldn't need to
customize any services right now.
But look around to see which options
you can change okay, and ignore this.
Okay, finally you can deploy it.
This might take a few minutes, so take a
break by visiting your favorite website.
All right, and there we go.
Everything is running.